[Music]
thank you
30 plus years of service
combat medals citations only man to
shoot down three enemy planes in the
last 40 years
yeah you can't get a promotion you won't
retire despite your best efforts you
refuse to die
you should be at least a two-star
Admiral by now
yet here you are
captain
what is that
it's one of life's mystery sir
[Music]
thank you
the end is inevitable Maverick you kind
of set it for extinction
maybe so sorry
but not today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
becoming quite a celebrity
[Music]
why is he writing to you
if you are Justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your Blind Eye
the hell are you supposed to be
I'm vengeance
this guy's crazy
foreign
[Music]
y the king
foreign
thank you Father my king
[Music]
father
[Applause]
's
day
[Music]
I
kill you I wanna learn you fun I want to
save you mother I won't kill you
why would this throw away to such a
hellish place
to find what was stolen for me and what
is that
you must choose between kindness for
your game
prayed for your enemies
your strength breaks Man's Bones
I have the cunning to break their minds
Night by night we will carry on my
pledge of engines
our adventure
foreign
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that I can't
I saw a sign in the sky
I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
can't I'm trying to protect you protect
me from what
it's time
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
whatever did this
I can kill it
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so I'm making like a little
documentary oh it's like a movie but
nobody has any lines and nobody even
knows what it is while they're making it
um no
[Music]
it's pretty much common knowledge that
it takes at least 20 shells to have a
community my cousin fell asleep in a
pocket and that's why I don't like the
saying everything comes out of the wash
because sometimes it doesn't or
sometimes it does and they're just like
a completely different person so it's
actually only two of us now myself and
my grandmother Nana Connie we like to
watch 60 minutes because Leslie's doll
is fearless
make the noise
sometimes I find my mind wandering
[Music]
my family think
[Music]
let's forget about being afraid just
take the adventure okay let's let's do
it
hi everybody
I'm recording this video because I'm
looking for my family
me anymore
[Music]
Marcel the Shell and the search for a
family reunited Marcel how long has it
been since you've seen your family I
couldn't tell you but the space in my
heart gets bigger and louder every day
Dean do you know how long that's two
years two years yeah oh that's nice to
know
[Music]
so many places that they could be
Marcel the Shell with Shoes On
[Music]
must be so many others like me
[Music]
he has got to go not that I don't like
Arthur
[Music]
did you know that the very first
assembly of photographs to create a
motion picture was a two second clip of
the black man on a horse
and that man is my great great
grandfather great there's another great
grandfather
but that's why back at the Haywood Ranch
as the only black owned horse trainers
in Hollywood we like to say since the
moment pictures could move
yes get in the game
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
it was a bad miracle
[Applause]
we gotta work for that
[Music]
[Music]
come on
yeah
I'm Leo you must be Nancy may I come
inside yeah
yeah so I've made a list of things that
I'd like to get through number one I
perform oral sex on you number two you
perform oral sex on me number three we
do a 69 if that's what it's still called
um four me on top five doggy style that
all sounds very achievable if I booked
enough time you you want to do it all
today
yes no
I've never had an orgasm there are nuns
out there with more sexual experience
that means embarrassing you want me to
brush my teeth
oh God this is crazy it's terrible it's
wrong Nancy yes come have a dance with
me
[Applause]
[Music]
now I simply don't understand why you're
doing this this to save up for our
College oh how wonderful are you really
no
hey
I've always been ashamed of my body your
body's beautiful I wish you could see
that
[Music]
everyone wants something different I
don't judge my clients unless they're
told virus holes
I've never done anything interesting in
my life
[Music]
you're the only Adventure I've ever had
what's the oldest person you've ever
done it with 82 82 yes 82. Nancy okay
I'm feeling a bit better now
I'll never take my power
[Applause]
an evil is coming
that threatens Our Kingdom
our freedom
but we have a weapon
[Music]
for
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
or we die
what if you must kill your teeth
[Music]
we are the homemade
Nick you've been living at the sunset
tower for over a year they love having
me there you owe them six hundred
thousand dollars okay I'm gonna deal
with all that but I'm gonna get this
next roll
and when I do all of that changes then
I'm back I'm not that you went anywhere
Nicolas Cage oh my God I love you
he was so good in the Rock what about
Gone in 60 Seconds have you seen Croods
too no I'm 44 years old why would I see
Cruz too I've seen Faceoff and Con Air
we got another offer what's it about you
head to southern Spain and you attend a
wealthy gentleman's birthday party
I would never do that it's a million
bucks Nick
I'll take it
the guy that owns this house what's his
name cubby yeah excuse me is Harvey
going to want me to uh you know I'm not
sure I understood
Nick Cage
[Applause]
I am so happy that you're here
supposed to be me
for a task I'll give you twenty thousand
for
eign
inspiration
I'm paranoid let's just get up from the
count of three and run they're coming
grab my hand
get happier than you look I have a very
big head
Rams
[Music]
Mr cage it turns out we could have just
walked around wow
[Music]
[Applause]